as the founder of infinity AI I hope to
make my startup a top Solutions provider
in the global artificial intelligence
Spectrum I believe that the skills that
I have acquired from the course in AI
for decision making from water will help
me take steps to expand my
business hey I'm tashad I live in pun
and I have my whole startup infi before
starting my own business I gained some
experience in the management domain I
worked with leading automotive players
like Mahindra and Tata as a senior
manager after getting more than 16 years
of experience I started my own set of
businesses I already knew how to make
business decisions but I was not sure
about the benefits that AI can provide
in a business when I launched my AI
startup taking a certification course
made sense after much thought and
research I opted for the AI for decision
making withs the strategies and
applications course I definitely gain
knowledge about various AI tools and
Services I also enjoyed the course it
was an awesome experience with respect
to the content and syllabus very easy to
understand the flow from the experts the
instructions actually help you improve
your grasp on the content it stays with
you the real life examples they provide
help you understand better I learned
about Big Data machine learning and much
more at infinite AI we'll be providing
AI based solutions to sectors ranging
from Healthcare banking Automotive
education Etc we will be helping
companies enhance their employee touch
points and customer experience basically
whever AI can be used now that I
understand the technology I think I am
better position we'll soon be launching
AI based products where the skills from
the bo will come handy I feel that I am
more considered as an entrepreneur now I
like to travel and meet new people I
like to explore various Avenues which is
quite risky upscaling can help you
reduce the
risk